hell is overflowing and Satan is sending
his dead you know mind detail seems to
be that the attackers in many instances
appear to be the bodies of the recently
deceased are returning to life and
attacking the living
[Music]
this is now the United States of
Zombieland every single person that you
or I has ever known dad your moms dads
brothers dad that fat chick at Dairy
Queen damn zombies might seem human that
make no mistake these creatures have
only one goal and that is to eat your
flesh I don't want to die here all right
we have to get out of here if we don't
they'll come up here and they'll tear us
to pieces let me know they're coming
it does that be apocalypse we're just
gonna stand here we're gonna go save the
world
all right Scouts let's kick some zombie
ass so how many of you
get cornered bash him in the head that's
work what do you think zombie kill a
week
I'm not kidding Tony
shoot them shoot them you have my
permission I ever turn into one of those
things
well my [ __ ] head on
[Music]